hi everyone
this is professor mdos science and today
i want to talk about exchange degeneracy
in another one of our videos on rigorous
quantum mechanics we will study a system
of
two identical particles we will find
that there are many
in fact infinitely many cats that can
describe a system of two identical
particles
this is a feature of quantum mechanics
that we call exchange degeneracy
however we will find out when we try to
make predictions
about our system using the usual rules
of quantum mechanics
something really really strange will
happen i will not say more at this stage
but i think you will enjoy the video
so let's go to understand exchange
degeneracy i will use the simplest
possible example
a two particle system from the video on
tensor product spaces we know that the
state space v
of a two particle system is the tensor
product of the single particle state
spaces of particles one
and two let's start with a single
particle and to make the example
even simpler we're going to limit our
discussion to the spin degree of rhythm
of a spin one half particle for example
an electron
this degree of freedom is described by a
two dimensional state space
and remember from the videos on spin one
half that the eigenstate of the
sz operator provides a basis for this
state space
this eigenstate are labeled by an up
arrow corresponding to eigenvalue plus h
bar over 2
and by a down arrow corresponding to
eigenvalue minus h bar over 2.
the state space of the second particle
is the same and we form the combined
state space by the tensor product here
the tensor product states space v has
dimension 4.
we can construct the basis for it by
calculating the tensor products of the
basis state of the individual state
spaces
and we get these four basis states here
remember that we typically use a much
simpler notation like this
where the order of the arrows indicates
to which of the single particle state
spaces they referred to
similarly the s that operators acting in
individual state spaces are now promoted
to operators acting in v like this
and for simplicity we typically write
them like this emitting the identity
operator and the tensor product sign
now that we have defined the state space
of two identical particles we imagine a
specific situation to exemplify exchange
degeneracy
let's imagine that we measure the z
component of the spin of both particles
and we obtain plus h bar over 2 for 1
and minus h bar over 2 for the other
we know that right after this
measurement one particle is in the up
eigen state
and the other particle is in the down
eigen state but which particle is in
which state
a first option is this state here
it corresponds to measuring particle 1
being up and particle 2 being down
which is consistent with the outcome of
the measurement up here
however these two particles are
identical which from the video on
identical particles we know it means
that the labels one
and two have no real physical
significance we can exchange the two
particles and the physical situation
will be exactly the same
this means that we can also write
another mathematically valid state like
this
and in this case we have that particle
one is down and particle two is up
the second state is also consistent with
having measured one particle up
and one particle down which is all we
can really say about our system because
these two particles are identical
so these two states both appear to be
consistent with the outcome of our
measurement
however these two states are not the
same state mathematically in fact they
are orthogonal
so which state do we have the one in
case one or the one in case two
the situation is actually even more
complicated if we take the two states up
here and we make an arbitrary limit
combination
that we insist is normalized then this
new state will
also describe the same physical
situation one particle up
one down to be more precise this is a
superposition state
and alpha is associated with the
probability of getting one up to down
while beta is associated with the
probability of getting one down to up
what this all means is that there are an
infinite number of possible states given
by the possible choices of alpha and
beta
and all these states appear to
mathematically describe the same
physical situation
this is what we call exchange degeneracy
and it is a feature of
any quantum mechanical system of
identical particles as the idea is
discussed here for two particles easily
generalized to more particles
so now we come to the critical question
of this video of all these
mathematically valid cats in our state
space
which one describes our physical system
another that may occur to you is that
all of these states are completely
equivalent
and any of them can be used to describe
our physical system
after all we have already encountered a
similar situation in our study of
quantum mechanics
we know that multiplying a state with a
global phase factor
gives a mathematically different state
but an equivalent physical state
this is true because none of the
predictions of quantum mechanics for
example the outcome of a measurement
depend on a global face let's test if
this is also what's happening here
if the states are truly equivalent and
describe the same physics
they should not only all capture the
state of the system right now but they
should also give us the same predictions
about what will happen next
after the first measurement of sz for
both particles we know that one is up
and one is down
and we have decided that any of the
state up here is a mathematically valid
state
now let's ask the question if we do a
second experiment
and we measure s x for both particles
what is the probability that we obtain
plus h bar over two for both particles
to answer this question first remember
from the videos on spin one half
particles
that the sx eigenstate of a single
particle corresponding to eigenvalue up
can be written in terms of the s z
eigenstates as
up x equals one over square root of two
up z plus down z so the tensor product
state after measuring sx to be
up for both particles is up up x
plugging in the expression here for a
single particle up state in the sz basis
we obtain the tensor product of this
first term
with this second term
and multiplying together these two terms
of the tensor product we obtain
up up up down down up
and down down i have mixed notation
somewhat in these expressions but it
should be clear what i mean in each case
so what is the probability of measuring
up up in the sx
state if we start with this state up
here
this probability is given by the overlap
between the up up as
x state and the starting state like this
we can then replace the expression for
the up up as x state in terms of the s z
basis we obtain here
and we get this long expression
the only combinations that don't give 0
in the bracket are this term
with this term and this term with this
term
therefore the result is absolute value
of one half alpha plus beta
all squared
what is this the prediction of the
outcome of a measurement depends on the
value of alpha and beta
depending on which of the states we pick
to describe the result of the first
as that measurement we will make a
different prediction for the outcome of
our second as
x measurement the situation is therefore
completely different
to that of a global phase factor these
states here are definitely not
equivalent because they don't lead to
the same
physics so what does this mean
we must remove exchange degeneracy and
decide from
all the mathematically allowed states
which one is the physically allowed one
before we say anything else i want to
generalize exchange degeneracy
to an n-particle system consider a cat
psi belonging to the state space v
of an n-particle system of identical
particles which as usual is given by the
tensor product of a single particle
states
also consider the n factorial cats p
alpha psi
given by all possible permutations of
the n particles
this set of cats span a subspace of v
which we call v
psi any state in vp psi is a state that
mathematically describes the same
situation because the particles are
identical
so this is exchange degeneracy for an n
particle system
just like we found for a two particle
system this gives rise to a big problem
all of these states are mathematically
describing our system but when we use
them to make physical predictions
using the usual rules of quantum
mechanics we get different answers
depending on which states we choose
this is a problem for any physical
theory and exchange degeneracy
must be removed so the big question
becomes
which of these states describes the
physical system
the answer to this question is by no
means trivial in fact
exchange degeneracy forces us to
introduce a new postulate to our quantum
mechanical formalism
to deal with systems of identical
particles the so-called
symmetrization postulate
well i hope you're somewhat puzzled and
that i have picked your curiosity
if you cannot wait to see how to resolve
the problem that exchange degeneracy
poses
go check out the video in this
metrization posture and as always
please subscribe
you